وفي معطى جديد اعلنت الرئاسه الاوكرانيه
ان الرئيس فلودي اصدر مرسوما بتشكيل مجلس
لتحرير القرن جاء ذلك بالتزامن مع اعلان
المخابرات الاوكرانيه استهداف خط حديدي في
شبه جزيره يستخدم او يستخدم لنقل الذخيره
والعتاد والجنود الروس
المسار المذكور لم يكن ينقل الحبوب فقط
وانما الاسلحه والذخيره والعربات المدرعه
ومجموعات القتال لمواصله العدوان الروسي
على اوكرانيا لقد ساعد ذلك الخط على قتل
المدنيين والمدافعين الاوكرانيين ومن
الطبيعي تماما ان مثل هذه المسارات لن
تستطيع التحمل وستتعرض للتعب والخروج عن
الخدمه لفتره معينه البنيه التحتيه في شبه
جزيره القرم ستعمل بشكل مسؤول وامن فقط
عندما يتم تحريرها من قبل اوكرانيا طالما
ظل الارهابيون الروس هناك فلن تعيش السلام
المنشود